what's going on guys welcome to the
third SFTP in Python video in this video
what we're gonna be talking about is how
to get a file from the server it's
actually pretty simple the only thing
that we're gonna need to do is change
from put to get and then also you want
to flip these right so when you're
putting it's like basically like a from
where to where right so this time when
you're getting you're getting from the
remote and then you want to put it to
the local path also just so we know that
we actually succeeded at this we can put
example like you know put two example
five text instead so we'll do that and
then you can just save that and run that
and as long as you don't get an error
let's check to see if we got that file
and sure enough there is our example 5
file we can open it up and again it's
the same thing right so the same file so
you can not only put up files you can
get the files and those are just the
basics of SFTP really FTP is just file
transfer but you can obviously use this
to update files and stuff like that
within your server also if you are
interested in learning more about SSH
and maybe executing various commands and
other things with SSH that paramiku
module that we installed at the
beginning here that is being used by
SFTP SFTP but really we're just doing
SFTP that module is pretty much the
go-to module within Python for SSH so
you could look more into that as well
and I do think you should look into the
PI crypto I do have a tutorial on that
it's pretty useful information to know
how to encrypt stuff before you send it
and then decrypt it when you get it so
anyway that's it with the tutorial
mini-series here for SFTP within Python
if you have any questions or you can't
figure something out feel free to leave
a comment below otherwise thanks for
watching